they wanted to stay put until their
hometowns were freed by Ukrainian troops
but now scores of people living in
russian-occupied territories of Ukraine
are scrambling to leave hope for
Liberation has faded ever since the
Kremlin announced a staged vote to Annex
four regions under its control desperate
to create facts on the ground Russia is
looking to seize 15 percent of Ukrainian
territory in a move the West has vowed
to never recognize
vote organizers in Donetsk making house
calls bringing the ballot boxes straight
to the people
amid the backdrop of War residents are
being asked to vote on joining the
Russian Federation
of course it's important we were
wondering when we would join Russia life
will be calmer
the so-called referendums are being held
over five days
Russian news outlets say most of the
voting will take place door to door
Kremlin installed leaders in the regions
have been preparing for months signing
up residents as Russian citizens
in luhans some see the vote as a way out
of war and deprivation
I think the referendum will be for the
best
yes that there will be water and
electricity and people will feel like
they are on their native land
but for those who fled to Ukrainian held
parts of zaparisa the votes are a sham
it's a violation of international law
it's a fake task to show that occupied
territories want to join the Russian
Federation
which is a total lie
once the so-called referendums are
completed Moscow could then claim that
its own territory is under attack with
weapons provided by the West
let's now bring in Catherine Lawler
she's a senior Analyst at The Institute
for the study of War welcome how closely
linked do you think are these Sham
referendums in occupy Ukraine to the
mobilization order in Russia
I think they're closely interrelated
announcing annexation and mobilization
within one week of one another makes
that clear and there's a few reasons
behind this so one of the driving forces
behind both are is the recent success of
Ukrainian counter-offensives
Putin expected this to be a 72-hour war
and instead he's eight months in and
he's losing Ukrainian forces are taking
back occupied Ukrainian territory bit by
bit and Russian forces are failing to
hold their front lines they desperately
need more manpower so the decision to
forcibly mobilize hundreds of thousands
of Russians is an attempt to address a
few of the short-term needs of Russian
forces it allows them to backfill their
front lines with untrained bodies
basically cannon fodder and if they
don't care about training their people
and a lot of evidence suggests they do
not care about training this first wave
of mobilized Personnel any more than
they've cared about training their
volunteer Battalion recruits you can
move some untrained forces forward
quickly but it's not going to have a
practical effect and one of the most
likely reasons why Russian President
Putin has linked annexation and
mobilization is that he can now exploit
a law that bans the deployment of
conscripts who haven't done such
training to conflicts abroad and if
Ukrainian territory is suddenly Russian
territory under Russian law Russia can
legally and openly deploy conscripts to
the front lines they've been doing that
all along but they'll increase those
deployments but if you're saying that
militarily it won't make a difference if
you throw let me phrase it that way
bodies at the problem why is he doing it
I think Russian military leadership May
believe that this will work but it's
actually going to exacerbate the
logistical challenges and Equipment
shortages and may even cause more
problems for Russia than for Ukraine but
I don't think they have a clear
understanding of what's actually
happening on the ground
let's talk about the annexation efforts
large parts of zapparigia and donates
are not under Russian control at the
moment what do you think Putin's plan is
there
honestly I think the plan is incoherent
uh the Kremlin is going to find itself
demanding that Ukrainian forces unoccupy
supposedly Russian territory but they
won't be able to enforce that demand and
by choosing to illegally Annex occupied
Ukraine and calling it Russian territory
they might be hoping to deter additional
Ukrainian counter-offensives and to
deter Western military aid to Ukraine by
falsely claiming that Western Equipment
is targeting Russian territory but I
think the Russians are underestimating
the Western will to support Ukrainian
sovereignty as well as disregarding
repeated and explicit Western statements
that Ukraine is within its rights to use
Western Equipment against Russian forces
on occupied Ukrainian soil including in
Crimea how willing do you think uh
Russia is to escalate the conflict once
there are counter attacks on what they
perceive to be their own territory
we'll have to wait and see but Russian
forces have not retaliated for Ukrainian
attacks into Crimea in an escalatory way
and I wouldn't expect them to be capable
of dramatic escalation in the near term
while they're still mobilizing these
forces
to what extent will ukrainians in the
occupied territories be forced by Russia
to fight against their own country now
um if Russia annexes these territories
which it will conscription will
absolutely apply to these newly annexed
territories uh forced mobilization has
been going on for years in the Russian
proxy controlled parts of Donetsk and
the hansk
um in some Villages that Russia has
occupied since 2014 there are no
Ukrainian men of fighting age left and
public preparations are already underway
in places like separagia and Carson to
forcibly mobilize Ukrainian civilians to
fight against the Ukrainian military
um likely with a metaphorical or
physical gun to their backs already back
in May you correctly predicted all of
what we're seeing today how do you see
the coming three months panning out
realistically I don't think Russia is
going to be able to raise enough quality
troops to change the course of this war
in the short term and probably not in
the long term either these reservists
they're not trained they're not
reservists like we would think of in the
US or Europe many have no experience or
maybe one year's experience as a
conscript decades ago many don't want to
fight so the Russians are making the
same mistakes that they've made all
along and they're throwing untrained men
at the front lines to backfill into
units that are already totally degraded
and demoralized
um they're exacerbating their own
logistical shortages so I think the war
isn't close to over it's not going to
end in the next three months but Ukraine
will conduct successive
counter-offensives into the new year to
continue to liberate its territory and
Russia's mobilization and annexation of
occupied Ukraine won't change the facts
on the ground which are that Ukraine is
advancing and Russian forces are falling
apart
we'll talk again in three months then
that was Catherine Lawler at The
Institute for the study of War many
thanks
thank you
let's bring in Maria kuznetsova she's a
spokeswoman for ovd info and independent
NGO monitoring political prosecution in
Russia Miss koznatsova do you see the
mood shifting are more Russians now
openly turning their back on Putin and
his war in Ukraine
yeah I would say that what we see now is
the change observation because for many
years uh there was an agreement between
Russian societies and Vladimir Putin
that the authorities do not intervene in
personal lives of people and in exchange
of that uh people do not ask questions
about politics and about human rights
violations but that has already changed
since Wednesday and we'll definitely see
a lot of people protesting who have
never done that and especially a lot of
human joints brought us who have never
seen such numbers have been Protestants
the protests we are seeing though are
mostly taking place in the bigger cities
in Moscow and St Petersburg how big is
descent really in in the rest of the
country
it's difficult to say precise numbers
but we've registered at least a few good
functions in more than 40 Russian
students so it's definitely not just
about Moscow and Saint Petersburg it's
also about forests Siberia and Central
Russia
in your latest report with ovd info you
you documented some of the arrests and
some of the things that happened to
people who went down to protest and were
arrested they were beaten they were some
of them forced into conscription we're
fairly used to seeing authorities crack
down on descent in Russia what's
different this time
and you're gonna I would say that police
is much more brutal now even comparing
to what happened in February and March
and what's really different is that 88
of people detained at protest in Saint
Petersburg for example they got arrest
of eight to ten days after the protest
we have never seen such big numbers of
people being arrested after the protest
for you know just a period of time and
it's also that 99 of people who want to
support after the process are found
guilty of illegal protests and it's also
a shift and I would say what the unique
is that now the police is openly calling
protesters traitors fascists Nazis and
say that after the protest you will go
to the war because you it's your
punishment to what extent do you think
though all of all of that we're seeing
right now the protests that descend the
arrests will have a tangible impact on
the war in Ukraine and Putin's effort to
to bolster troops
I shall see now that a lot of people are
fleeing the country for example and I
would say that both protests and people
live in Canada not directly influence
what's happening but it can start uh
other ways of social disobedience in
Russian Society Maybe started to work or
just you know living Works in Mass
amounts and I would say that probably
will have a huge impact but still I
think it's really important that people
try you know not to go to the war and
just show that Russians results through
Israel depressions who do not agree with
the war Maria kozansova of OBD info
thanks for your time and all this
information
thank you
United Nations is wrapping up its first
in-person Gathering of world leaders
since the start of the pandemic Russia's
escalation of the war in Ukraine has
dominated proceedings in New York the
West led by the United States has
condemned the Kremlin for making veiled
threats to use nuclear weapons Russia
says Western allies have become party to
the conflict by supplying weapons to
Keith
is in New York City for us and is
following the meeting Michelle has the
UN resolved anything in terms of Ukraine
well the UN simply can't because Russia
is part of the security Council now its
task is to maintain a peace and Security
in the world and it is completely
dysfunctional that is shown by the
conflict in Ukraine so the short answer
is no nothing was resolved here
certainly when it comes to the conflict
in Ukraine that Russian aggression there
but the biggest tangible outcome is that
clearly the trend is Shifting against
Russia
um Sage lavrov the Russian foreign
minister was at Payne's to maintain the
rhetoric that Russia had been putting
from day one that there was a Liberation
operation that there was a suppression
of Russians well nobody is buying this
here and more and more countries simply
want this conflict to go away Russia is
well on its way to becoming a pariah
State and that certainly helps those
allies standing together trying to push
back Russia now notably China and India
too important U.N Powers have not openly
condemned Russia's actions do we know
where they stand
yeah this is a very interesting one I
mean it clearly would be in China's
interest to see Europe continuing and
the United States continuing to struggle
with this conflict but Vladimir Putin
made a huge mistake the this week for
sure when he made that second nuclear
threat as all world leaders were
gathering Here China wants to see itself
in a role of a moderating force but it
wants this conflict to end it's been
quite clear in signaling that and India
too which is highly dependent on Russia
because it's really so close is also
tangibly running out of patients
recognizing that that was actually
started by the Russian side so it's a
lot in the Diplomatic detail but also
very key allies are increasing their
pressure may be it implicit or direct
whether it's direct we do not know we're
not on those conversations on Vladimir
Putin to back down so whatever he
threatens now he will be pretty much
alone on the world stage if he
exacerbates that situation any further
and also there's many tiny countries
small countries here who are simply
running out of patients because they
want to talk about the effects of
climate change that their people are
feeling every day and once again Ukraine
dominated the agenda here
our correspondence
reporting from New York City thank you